[Music]  that's better watch have you stayed in  that they watch shake that crazy  Baywatch no that was pretty intense  shape that involves training two four  seven that was six days a week  4:30 in the morning so what you're  saying right now is you let it go  I did let it go I always maintain health  and fitness for life I don't need to be  that buff to just give interviews and  stuff you you wake up last week or week  before and you hear that you broke  Parrish Jackson's heart I did not know  this is the first I'm hearing of it I'm  bummed out first concert the first one  that I like actively really wanted to  see was a high school musical life oh my  god  Zac Efron like oh my god I'm like ten  year old  I'll have to make it up to her so yeah  of course absolutely in some way I'm  sure we'll cross paths at some point  look at all so yeah much love until then  [Music]